[Music]
you're going to tell us everything you
know
i'm not telling you a [ __ ]
you can electrocute him all day it'll
only make him angrier i
on the other hand will tell you
everything really
michael bryce was trying to put his past
behind him you need to forget
bodyguarding repeat after me
no bodyguarding no
to protect this homicidal nut bags wife
what is he doing here
i said get anyone but michael rice
i believe it's pronounced thank you
in four days all of you loved was burned
they're planning a full-scale cyber
attack do not scoop this up
oh we are definitely going to scoot this
up
i promised my therapist no bodyguarding
let's not do that guys let's just focus
i got it no it's fine you guys just you
guys have had him
maybe feather the break a bit i need you
to protect us good time to have a baby
we gotta have mercy on ourselves now
repeat after me i'm unlicensed
i'm unlicensed that's terrible louder
i'm unlicensed
and i don't give up we need guns
we need boats we need them are you ready
to get your free con
what that came out wrong not together
with us that also came out wrong now
let's go do what we do
and blow some things up
i would make a great mother tongue i
think you're good
thank you it must be your powerful
asexuality that makes you such a good
listener
we just acknowledge that not only are we
safe this really feels like a newbie
every warrior has the beginning
i'm on a new level for 600 years
our ninja had brought peace
i need warriors like
the journey from here
is yours to decide
but that is just the beginning i'm on a
new level
[Music]
[Applause]
i say either yeah either
i see neither can i say neither neither
either
neither neither let's call the whole
thing off
catch up excuse me
yummy
good evening eddie hey mrs chen good
evening venom
this is jen he says hi
you and i are the same
[Music]
every decision we ever make
[Music]
who do we leave behind and how do we
leave them waiting
in the darkness of the rescuer who never
comes
welcome back eddie brock it's been a
long time
miss you so much
come chaos
chaos soon
the chocolate delivery hasn't arrived
yet no we had a deal
what's gonna happen you're gonna stop
protecting me i am happy to eat mrs chen
no
no you cannot eat mrs chen what nothing
the annual purge will conclude in three
two one
thank you for your participation
we survived all police and emergency
services have been reinstated
all crime including murder is now
illegal come on let's get to work
one night only rest of the year is
peaceful
help me help me
the purge is over please
no it ain't this is insane
nobody hear the sirens there's no crime
anymore
anything else you rich can't hide behind
your steel walls no more
powerless how does that feel is the real
purge the forever purge
hurry up they're coming
come on follow me there's nowhere safe
to go
no way to get help oh my god
we gotta find another way to get out of
[Music]
here
this country's gonna collapse
mexico was opening its borders for the
next six
we're hours this together
does this translate
friends
brothers and sisters
who can regale me and my queen with some
myth
oh
oh greatest of kings let one of your
knights
try to let them blow against me indulge
me in this game
i'm ready
one year
hence
[Music]
was it not just a game perhaps but it is
not complete
you'll find no mercy
no happier
why do you stop me
you rest your bones i'll finish your
quest for you
and what do you hope to gain
from facing all of this
honor
that is why knight does what he does
[Music]
are you ready
[Applause]
granny's out here having a martini at
halftime
16th the test is ready
rachel wrote ross a letter and demanded
he read it before they got back together
how many pages was that letter 18 pages
18 pages
front and back front and back is correct
wait wait don't worry
oh my god here we go
where's the tissue box
[Music]
the
[Applause]
does courtney still have her lines
written on the table
[Music]
we've literally just slipped right back
[Applause]
we regret we have such a bond
from this show were ross and rachel on a
break
yes yes yes yes [ __ ]
[Applause]
the first table read that's the first
time i laid eyes on any of you
everyone was so perfectly cast yeah
this is from the one where everyone
finds out
[Laughter]
i remember i went to the producer of the
show i was on
and he said that show's not gonna make
you a star
i remember one time i'd have to have the
news on and on the tv
was an aerial shot of each of our houses
oh
geez i remember looking at it going what
my roof
is a mess
it was an incredible time we became
best friends yeah i'm gonna cry now
when i watch the episodes i'm laughing
out loud because you all make me laugh
so hard i know you know how big the show
is what you have given so many people is
an experience of huge comfort oh my god
we felt like we had these friends i love
you guys so much
[Music]
here's to hotel transylvania
johnny works so hard to make this extra
special
thank you dear son-in-law
ruined everything johnny what are you
talking about your dad never really
thought of me as part of the family
all because i'm not a monster so you
want to become a monster huh
van helsing demonstration ray turns
humans into monsters and monsters into
humans but is this safe though
great question
that's weird nothing happened
[Music]
the nightmare it's over i'm human again
hey drac what's up connie oh
[Music]
you're a human and i'm a monster it's
like freaky friday
but on a tuesday though
what's going on
my first
what's up fellas frank oh i'm balding
the day you left for marseille
i drove to the airport i went to the
gift shop
and i saw this necklace it was gold
said still water on it i thought it'd be
a little piece of home to take with you
you're in masai for
engagement no this isn't my daughter
yep the father of the girl the american
student
yes ma'am
allison came here for college and that's
where she met this girl
lina one night she found leanna dead and
called the police
all they cared about was a thousand
sleeping with some arab girl
i loved her i know you did but everybody
thinks that i killed her
we have exhausted every possible league
election is the
lawyer not helping you i'm doing it
myself for now
i what's could name
maya that's nice she's very protective
with me
you seen that guy before no one would
talk to you trust me
i'm not from here it's not safe for you
she's my little girl
[Music]
i'm not gonna give up
it will be a serious mistake to commit a
crime to prove your daughter innocent
it will not get her out of jail let me
send you in
lord please keep the watchful eye on
allison amen
did you ask her to lie i'm trying to get
my little girl out of jail that's all i
give a damn about
you sound very american right now good i
am
yeah and you're also a stranger here
what did you do
you just have to trust me
excuse me she's been like crying for
hours sorry but this is a group for new
mothers on that sign out there it says
parents i'm a parent and i don't know
what the hell i'm doing
girl's got some stuff flying out of ass
so she can either hit you with a
streamer or she'll buckshot you
it's a quick walk i need help
i don't know how you're going to do this
if you've had only one parent i wish you
could have had your mom
because she would have been better at it
and mommy was the best
matthew darling we think you should move
back to minnesota you're all alone here
she needs family raising a child it's a
non-stop all day all night up there i
look you look great don't say it just to
be saying that you look like a king
king of the slain how does it look
i think it's a new look i think it's a
new hairstyle that can catch on if given
a chance
mr lokman madeline doesn't have a mother
to model after i am well aware
of what my daughter doesn't have you
think you can do this but you can't
no man you're right i can't do it but
you know what i'm going to do it
because i'm a father
[Music]
my god maddie you thank god the day i
got there in time
to hold her hand liz
i didn't get to hold her hand she was
gone and you
it's always just us other people have
more people
wrong i just want to do what your mom
would have wanted me to do
i promised that i'm trying to make
everything
perfect
wherever you are i want to go there too
somebody's cutting onions or something
close to us or something i don't know
hey y'all gotta stop it oh
she wouldn't be so proud of you
[Music]
two kisses
[Music]
he okay maddie yeah
dear evan hansen today is going to be an
amazing day and
here's why
[Music]
have you been doing those letters to
yourself with dr sherman i've been
trying to
have you ever felt like nobody was there
um no one signed your cast now we can
both pretend we have friends
i'm sorry about my brother have you ever
felt forgotten
in the middle of nowhere i wish
everything was different
i wish i was part of something i wish
that anything i said
mattered have you ever felt like you
could disappear
dear evan hansen yeah yeah that's mine
i'll i'll just take it wait i really i
need that back
he could fall and no one would hear
connor took a letter from me it was an
assignment for my therapist too
even when the dark comes crashing
through connor's mother and step father
here to see you
when you need a friend to carry you
connor wanted you to have this is when
you're broken on the ground
dear evan hansen he wrote it to you his
last awards
conor took his own life hey what
i'm sorry connor didn't write this no no
please it's this
you will be fine we didn't think connor
had any friends
[Music]
and are you really going to tell these
people that the only thing they have
left of their son
was a letter that you wrote to yourself
so you and connor tell us something
please
right um i started talking and you
couldn't stop they didn't want me to
stop
i'm putting together memorial service if
you wanted to do something
conor showed me that i wasn't alone
nobody is so let that lonely feeling
wash away
maybe there's a reason to believe you'll
be okay i didn't know that you were here
[Music]
people started sharing it it's
everywhere i don't understand what
happened
you did you don't know how much you've
given my family
were you ever actually friends with him
i never meant to make it such a mess i
was trying to help
you who i am just how broken i am
[Music]
i already know you
and i love you
i have to tell them
how is aretha doing
all right just all right
singing is sacred and you shouldn't do
it just because somebody wants you to
what's most important is that you are
treated with dignity and respect
your specialty you have a talent they
call
genius
[Music]
i need you to focus and avoid frivolous
distractions
honey find the songs that move you until
you do that
you ain't going nowhere
i need a change i want to sing what i
want to sing
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you really like it we love it riri
re-read
by this new chick named aretha franklin
you're not about to mess this up for me
ladies and gentlemen
this song goes out on the morning to
anyone who's ever felt
mistreated
you need to take a break i know how to
run my business have you lost your
maybe i found it i believe i have the
chills
[Music]
do you see what she is
[Music]
[Music]
if you could wish for anything delivery
have a nice day thank you delivery thank
you
[Music]
what would it be hey lina happy birthday
i miss oh you
oh gosh um
a peasant boy well this will be easy
i know what you're thinking could this
be real is magic
real yes it's real
i am a wish dragon who will grant three
wishes
to the owner of this teapot
how do you fit in this teapot it's so
small look at your little arms
your face is so soft oh can you breathe
fire
now i've been stuck in this teapot
for a thousand years so the sooner we
can get this over with
the better
[Music]
excellent choice you see her i wish
stop stop stop stop stop stop i can't
make people fall in love with you
no she's my best friend ten years ago
[Music]
bye tim that's my wish i want my friend
back
[Music]
i'm going to need that teapot i wish i
knew how to fight
[Music]
hop on
best friends forever
i wish
i wish this traffic would just yes go
ahead long
i'm not gonna waste a wish on traffic
look you're gonna have to use your
you're gonna have to use you're gonna
have to
you're gonna have to use it if only i
had a magical dragon that could fly me
across the city
[Music]
[Music]
germany
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
you